Oh sliding into your DMS I mean that
sounds nasty I don't want to when
sliding into my DMS they take a bath
first I am part Greg and you're about to
be schooled ninety style okay right so
today we have a thing called Wi-Fi you
know there really was nothing like Wi-Fi
if anything we had a modem you'd have to
plug into your phone line you do this
bizarre squealing sound like a
science-fiction rat was being killed and
then suddenly this guy's voice would
come on and he'd say you've got mail so
it was very early days she felt very
cutting-edge if you even had male car DB
man I love me some car DB she brings the
truth wherever she goes
and you complete me but she has no to
give back in the day we had some pop
stars
you had your Britney Spears big Britney
fan you've ever seen lip-sync battle you
know I'm a huge Britney fan
[Music]
okay flossing I'm familiar with it I've
tried to do it didn't go so well
I might have dislocated my shoulder I'd
like to say that the really cheesy dance
crazes back in our day the Macarena
[Music]
hammer time
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel like most people could kind of do
it I think it's kind of mean that now
we've got a dance craze that like it's
really designed to make you look stupid
on YouTube Bluetooth speakers yeah the
whole wires thing everything had wires
so the idea that you could just walk in
and go hey can I put on my jams and have
us someone like let me just click you to
the Bluetooth that was unheard of you
had people walking around with a boombox
on their shoulders that was you know
basically the size of their body you
would have a boombox like this you could
put in your cassette tape unless it was
messed up and then you had to get a
pencil and stick it in the cassette tape
and wind it all up so that it wasn't
ruined even so from then on when you got
to that part of the song you'd hear
another one of those alien creatures
like me baby yeah hey there's me okay
now we have Funko pops something
collectible they're really technically a
bobble head this big head bobbles it was
a big day for me when I got one of those
I love the people at Funko's and the old
days people collected beanie babies even
at the time it made no sense to me
they're kind of little cheap looking
stuffed animals and people would pay
thousands and thousands of dollars to
get that one elusive unicorn or whatever
was the beanie baby they wanted I mean I
hope those people are rich now I know
kids it makes no sense it made no sense
to me that either
right now we have a deist Yeezys Easy's
from yay yeah they're very cool I see
him on people personally I'm a fan of
the Jordans I'm a big fan of Spidey
verse so I had to break out my Jordan
once that's what we were rocking then
I'm not gonna lie you see those walking
around now so there's only one Jordan
smartphones okay my phone was dumb as
dirt and it was bigger than my shoe it
would run out of batteries very fast but
I still felt very secret-agent driving
around in my car
and get this making a call in my car in
the old days like I don't even know who
the Green Hornet maybe had a phone in
his car Batman had a phone in his car
nobody else Netflix Netflix didn't make
shows please it was a no interface we
would go down to the blockbuster
together and you would pick out the
movies you wanted to see some from a
long time ago and all
so you'd hope the most recent ones
weren't already all rented out you know
some things you could only get them on
VHS that's that's all you had and that
was a cassette and at the end of it the
big thing was be kind rewind you had to
either we think the thing all the way
back because sometimes you would get a
movie that someone hadn't done that and
you'd put it in your VCR to watch the
movie and you'd see the end of the movie
talk about a spoiler alerts those people
were not popular lit its lit I mean I
have a dad and even I think lid is over
all that in a bag of chips that's a
thing we heard in the 90s this is fat
dude with a pH I could never pull any of
it off Oh
sliding into your DMS I mean that sounds
nasty I don't want to when sliding into
my DMS unless they take a bath first
we had like AOL chat rooms or physically
you would actually go up and chat with
somebody with varying degrees of success
if you were me this has been clark gregg
class dismissed
[Music]